et la chronique écho de ce jeudi soir
c'est avec vous Marguerite Guillet
bonsoir vous êtes vice-présidente de
l'association Créactive vous êtes
vous-même femme chef d'entreprise
puceque c'est une association qui ne
regroupe que des femmes chef
d'entreprise on va donc en parler c'est
une association Créactive qui a vu le
jour il y a 10 ans à peu près vous vous
y êtes adhérante depuis 3 ans alors
pourquoi vous avez adhéré à cette
association est-ce que c'est c'est
rassurant d'être toutes ensemble ouais
c'est un peu ça ouais moi dans mon cas
ça c'est passé de fil en aiguille
c'était l'ancienne vice-présidente qui
cherchait à se faire remplacer en fait
moi je cherchais à intégrer un réseau et
puis ça s'est fait comme ça et quand
vous dites je cherchéis à intégrer un
réseau parce que c'est indispensable
vous votre dans votre activité vous êtes
toute seule vous êtes dans la
communication vous travaillez tout seul
oui ah il faut pas s'isoler enfin d'un
are côté je travaille en effet toute
seule mais il y a plein de monde autour
de moi c'est parce que on est seul à la
tête de son affaire que on est
isolé mais en revanche oui je je alors
intégrer un réseau c'est
pas c'est pas obligatoire en soi mais
c'est plutôt conseiller oui forcément
parce qu'on a besoin de mouvement faire
des AFF parce que du coup on discute
avec d'autres femmes chefs d'entreprise
qui n don des conseils problématiqu
qu'on sa'est peut-être pas bien qu'on
sa'est pas réglé quand on démarre dans
un métier c'est normal oui tout fait oui
complètement oui oui B c'est sûr que
c'est aussi pour
c'est c'est certain pour certaines
personnes moi c'était pas mon cas mais
c'est vrai que pour beaucoup de monde ça
ça ça peut être
ça et puis c'est pour chercher des
conseils pour pour trouver des
partenaires trouver évidemment du
business enfin du business àéactive ah
oui oui complètement ou ouais ouais j'ai
d l'association existe depuis 10 ans
combien d'adhérents parce que il y a que
des femmes voilà on est une bonne
cinquantaine oua voilà et puis et que
propose l'association alors alors nous
en fait on regroupe à la fois des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont déjà donc monté
leur affairire et des porteus de projets
euh une fois par mois on se regroupe au
Promopole de montiné Bretonneux euh et
on se voit alors on organise des
réunions chaque mois sur des thématiques
différentes qui ont toutes forcément
comme tronconin l'entrepreneuriat euh
voilà puis ça se termine ça se termine
autour d'un verre pour voilà
convivialité la prochaine réunion
c'est demain soir à 19h30 à Promopole à
Montin brantonneuse sur la thématique
des réseaux sociaux alors les réseaux
sociaux amis ou
ennemis ça dépend de quel point de vue
on se place non mais je sais pas ça peut
ça paraît ça paraît en fait une
ouverture vers le monde mais alors après
si on est tout le temps sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que c'est pas trop
dangereux quel
conseilors d'abord c'est dangereux si on
sait pas comment ça marche je pense que
c'est surtout une histoire d'éducation
entre guillemets de connaissance du
système euh après c'est ni ami ni ennemi
encore une fois c'est euh c'est un c'est
c'est un médiia
euh voilà on peut on peut s'en service
on peut s'en servir pour communiquer
pour pour voilà pour communiquer mais
mais vous dites il faut bien le
connaître ça ve dire qu'il y a quand
même des pièges à éviter c'est pas des
pièges en tant que tel mais disons que
pour bien s'en servir oui il faut il
faut il faut connaître les règles mais
c'est comme tous hein c'est euh après
c'est vrai que on a S souvent tendance à
diaboliser les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'on sait aussi pas trop où ça commence
et où ça
finit je cach quand même une conférence
débat puisque vous l'animez demain soir
sur cette thématique là c'est donc y a
je présume de la demande ou ah
complètement oui ah oui oui oui beaucoup
de beaucoup de de de petites entreprises
sont présents sur les réseaux sociaux
ont ouvert un compte parce que ils
savent que c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'un peu incontournable aujourd'hui
puisque c'est là où c'est les gens se
trouvent enfin en tout cas une grande
majorité euh mais après les gens savent
pas forcément trop comment s'en servir
ni vraiment pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
ouvert un compte si ce n'est finalement
pour faire comme les autres demain donc
nous demain soir en fait on va vraiment
on va on va expliquer un petit peu
comment ça fonctionne pourquoi c'est
bien et surtout comment il faut s'en
servir voilà avec une méthodologie du
coup oui alors donc c'est demain soir à
19h30 au promopo de montin3 19 excuse-mo
on va faire une pause dans cette
chronique écho quelle est selon vous
l'importance d'être en réseau c'est la
question que nous sommes allés poser
dans les rues de Saint-Quentin on écoute
la réponse des Saint-Quentin je sais
qu'il en existe mais je pense que c'est
important en particulier pour préparer
l'avenir là je pense que 50 an en
evveline on a besoin que nos grandes
entreprises réfléchissent ensemble sur
l'avenir de 50 en evveline une entraine
je je suppose apporter pas
mal
d'infos très très très très important on
peut pas s'en passer aujourd'hui pouri
parce que ça permet de mettre enfin
d'être d'avoir la bonne personne au bon
moment au bon endroit euh d'être sûr de
la personne parce que ça passe par les
réseaux professionnels de faire circuler
l'information de valider
l'information d'avoir de l'information
faire des affaires et pas rester seul ça
peut fournir des clients
effectivement on peut se s'entraider
effectivement s'envoyer des clients et
quand on est envoyé par une autre
entreprise de connaissance ça peut
faciliter les choses bah l'important
c'est que s'il nous arrive un souci euh
dans notre travail ça nous permet
d'avoir des connaissances autour de nous
et de les faire fonctionner
ah c'est important le réseau on peut pas
s'en passer 10 cette dames al je sais
pas si ça va jusque là on peut pas se
passer du réseau le réseau c'est le
mouvement et puis par définition le
réseau c'est un groupe de personnes he
on peut pas exister seul on existe aussi
parce qu'il y a des autres donc là on ou
ça veut dire que l'association Créactive
elle a aussi ce but là de de mettre les
gens en réseau ah ouiè liens tout à
faitou et vous dit de faire des affaires
aussi he parce qu'on un monsieur qui
disait oui on peut faire des affaires
oui en effet ben le réseau oui par
définition on est on est tous ensemble
après on en fait aussi ce qu'on est venu
chercher hein donc effectivement il y a
des femmes qui vont venir qui vont venir
à CréActif parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'avoir des conseils sur la manière de
tenir leur
affaires il y a d'autres personnes qui
qui effectivement viennent viennent à
Créactive parce qu'elles ont besoin
elles démarrent donc elles ont
effectivement besoin du réseau aussi
pour mettre le pied à l'étrier trouver
des clients pourquoi pas aussi créer des
synergies puisque quand on est seul
quand on est seul à la tête de son
entreprise on a aussi parfois pour X
raison je sais pas moi répondre à un
appel d'offre quelque chose besoin
d'autres compétences qui vont être
complémentaires à la sienne et du coup
le réseau
F alors selon un sondage auin we 69 %
des femmes estiment que la création
d'entreprise c'est beaucoup plus
épanouissant que le salariat donc on dit
69 % c'est super elles sont toutes
prêtes à se lancer mais dans la réalité
on sent que les femmes n'osent pas des
fois se lancer dans la création
d'entreprise ou en tout cas quand elles
se lance c'est plutôt dans des
micro-entreprises que de reprendre des
grosses entreprises est-ce que vous le
vous le constatez ça est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord ou est-ce que vous dites
ah non non c'est un discours dépassé non
c'est je sais pas si c'est un discours
dépassé en tout cas nous on est une
association
cquantinoise et c'est vrai que la
plupart de nos membres sont des
personnes sont des personnes qui
représentent des toutes petites
entreprises des micro-entreprises VO
même des autoentrepris eneur on a
vraiment c'est très hétéroclite hein on
a euh plein de
typologies d'entreprises différentes euh
après dire
que une femme aura plus de difficultés à
à créer une grosse
structure je suis pas si sûre que ça
parce Queel selon toujours le même
sondage 33 % des sondés considèrent
qu'être une femme représente un
désavantage dans la création
d'entreprise est-ce que vous-même qui
avez créé votre entreprise vous avez à
un moment donné ressenti que être une
femme c'était plus compliqué que si vous
aviez été un homme ou pas du tout en
fait alors oui je je je enfin c'est pas
que je pense que c'est plus compliqué
encore une fois je pense que c'est
vraiment c'est culturel euh ah oui c'est
culturel encore ou je pense oui je pense
que c'est culturel oui oui oui un homme
par définition aura certainement plus
d'avantage à créer une entreprise qu'une
femme parce que une femme aura peut-être
pas nécessairement l'idée
instinctivement de se dire j le droit je
peux le faire et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est cultur alors
c'est de la culture judéo-chrétienne
c'estàdire en gros la femme à la maison
encore c'est un peu ça ouais en tout
cas oui bien sûr non mais ah
complètement puisqu'on est là donc bien
sûr ça évolue et puis bien sûr mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a il y a
effectivement cette faculté de se dire
je peux le faire j'ai pas j'y a droit
mais c'est possible et c'est pas quelque
chose qui est très véhiculé encore
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour les femmes
et quand vous recevez pour les jeunes
aussi pour les jeunes ah oui pour les
jeunes femmes c'est qu'on pourrait pour
les jeunes je mets un peu peu dans le
même là on sort peêre un peu du contexte
mais aussi pour les jeunes c'est-àdire
que maintenant un jeune qui qui a 25 ans
se sentira certainement moins légitime
qu'une personne qui a 20 ans de de de de
d'expérience professionnelle et à la
limite je vois pas pourquoi
effectivement il y a le bagage en plus
l'entrepr oui mais l'entrepreneuriat
c'est aussiamisme je et puis et puis
l'entrepreneuriat c'est c'est c'est
aussi pas une mentalité mais une un état
d'esprit voilà et ça qu'on soit jeune ou
pas on l' l' pas vous a poussé à créer
votre entreprise vous étiez salarié je
présume avant oui et alors qu'est-ce qui
vous a donné envie de franchir le pas
rbol du
patron comme 69 % vous étiez pas épanoui
dans votre travail comme 69 % V moi je
rentre ouais ouais je rentre je rentre
clairement dans
le dans dans vos chiffres oui oui c'est
vrai c'était ça en fait je trouvais pas
je je je je trouvais pas un poste qui me
définissait en effet et là vous êtes
plus épanoui en tant que chef
d'entreprise ah complètement mais c'est
aussi a le stress que ça PE présenter
c'est-à-dire de se dire il faut que je
fasse mon chiffre à la fin du mois j'ai
mes charges à payer il faut oui il faut
que je mange bien sûr ou oui oui en
effet mais c'est je pense c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est vraiment un état
d'esprit et et ça on n'est pas obligé
d'être vieux on n'est pas obligé d'être
un homme ou une femme et inversement
enfin voilà il y a pas de il y a pas de
typologie précise pour ça quoi vous
restez encore en plateau avec nous on va
faire une une pause dans cette chronique
écho on va aller du côté de voisin le
Bretonneux au parc où Europe car vient
d'installer son siège social France
Bonjour 10000 m Carr au cœur du parc
d'affaires du Val Saint-Quentin à voisin
le Bretonneux c'est le nouveau siège d'
ropecar France installé auparavant
pendant plus de 30 ans à Montini 200
salariés ont pris leur quartier depuis 6
mois l'esprit d'avoir un parc d'activité
avec des espaces verts et pour nous un
changement qui est bénéfique par rapport
à nous étions auparavant avoir son siège
dans les Yvelines c'est être au plus
proche des constructeurs aut notamment
Renault et Peugeot Citroën mais aussi de
ses clients c'est un bassin économique
qui se développe donc nous avons aussi
un certain nombre de clientèle clients
soit PME PMI ou grand compte des clients
àaires qui sont aussi sur le Passin
économique qui se développ une enseigne
de taille pour le promoteur Codic
gestionnaire de ce parc d'affaires le
valsint-quentin a commencé ses travaux
en 2002 en mettant l'accent sur les
normes environn mal nous avons commencé
à acquérir les premiers biens en 2000 et
nous avons ont commencé à construire les
trois premiers bâtiments en 2002 sans
financement bancaire puisque personne ne
croyait en cette aventure puisque que le
concept du parc est un peu un parc à
anglo-saxon avec notamment beaucoup de
parkings en sous-sol tous les bâtiments
de cette phase répondent à la RT 2012
donc nous sommes assez loin en norme
environnementale les bâtiments ont tous
une signature bréam verygout donc encore
des normes qui sont assez élevées en
Europe en tout 13 bâtiments composeront
à terme le val Saint-Quentin sont déjà
installés Adidas rebook Yazaki Siemens
ou encore bentler Automotive livraison
des derniers bâtiments prévus en 2014
allez on retrouve Marg Guillet donc
vice-présidente de l'association
Créactive association de qui regroupe
des femmes chefs d'entreprise justement
si vous aviez un conseil à donner au
chef aux femmes chefs d'entreprise ou
aux femmes qui voudrai se lancer ou aux
femmes qui viennent de se
lancer de se faire accompagner mais ça
je pense que c'est pas spécifique aux
femmes
je pense que quelqu'un qui a un un
projet a justement besoin de s'entourer
et a besoin du réseau aussi pour prendre
du recul mais ça de toute
façon donc on reste pas seul hein
surtout oui mais on reste pas seul parce
que ça aide aussi à prendre du recul en
effet et et je pense que je pense que de
toute façon ça on en a besoin tout le
temps parce que parfois bah oui on est
on est un peu à fond on a besoin de et
le réseau permet aussi ça de prendre du
recul alors est-ce que chez Créactive on
est un peu féministe comment alors on n
pas de oui alors après réducteur comme
question je m' de vous la poser au
moment où je la pose hyper réducteur
donc je retiens ma question est-ce qu'on
est un peu féministe quand même alorsi
je ça dépend de ce
qu'on ça dépend de la définition qu'on
donne à féministe nous on n'est pas des
intégriste après si vous me posez à moi
la question je diroui moi je suis
féministe mais je suis pas intégriste
non mais cétait c'était un enchaînement
pour vous demander en fait ce que vous
pensez notamment la lois sur la parité
dans l'entreprise et notamment en
janvier 2014 les femmes qui devront
constituer % des effectifs des Conseils
d'Administration des Entreprises alors
je sais pas c'est bien c'est dommage de
faire une loi pour ça mais bon
finalement ça va peut-être faire avancer
des ch problème c'est que c'est que s'il
y a une loi c'est que il sont peut-être
aussi obligés quelque part le problème
il est là c'est
que c'est c'est un un un un problème
récurrent qui a toujours existé ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle mais il s'est
jamais rien passé alors est-ce qu'on
doit être obligé de passer par une loi
ben peut-être que peut-être que oui
peut-être que je après malheureusement
je bon on verra dans les on verra dans
les merci beaucoup Mar d'êt venu sur le
plateau et je rappelle la prochaine
réunion des créactifs ce sera demain
soir vendredi 28 septembre à 19h30
Promopole de Montini sur le sur le la
thématique des réseaux sociaux on va
rester dans le on va passer au domaine
de l'automobile audi fait son show à
Vézy en posant la première pierre de son
terminal une sorte de showroom on va
écouter d'ailleurs le directeur général
d'Audi France il va nous expliquer sa
stratégie le site emploira à terme 60
personnes l'idéeavant tout c'est de
représenter Audi sur l'ouest de Paris où
nous n'étions pas présents jusqu'à
maintenant euh et donc avec un bâtiment
qui soit le plus représentatif de la
marque c'est ce qu'on appelle le concept
terminal qui a été développé par un
cabinet d'architecte munikois et où vous
retrouvez tout l'univers de la marque en
un seul endroit avec l'avantgardisme la
sportivité et bien sûr le raffinement de
D on va faire de cette concession comme
d'autres affaires en France un lieu de
découverte de la marque pour nos clients
un lieu où on se sent chez soi où on se
sent appartenir à la marque comme dans
une famille et donc on profitera de
l'occasion d'une d'une affaire comme
celle-là pour présenter des nouveaux
modèles comme c'est le cas actuellement
avec le lancement de la nouvelle A3 qui
sera présenté au Salon de Paris mais
également peut-être des opérations avec
des des véhicules un peu extraordinaires
comme des véhicules de sport ou des
véhicules qu'on a pas l'habitude de voir
sur la route on est sur un plan
aujourd'hui d'environ 60 personnes qui
seront qui travailleront sur site donc
une trentaine de techniciens pour la
partie après-vente puis ensuite une
partie administrative et bien sur les
commerciaux pour toute la partie vente
de de véhicules neuf et d'occasion quand
on cherche un
endroit pour s'installer dans
l'automobile avec une force visibilité
qui soit cohérent par rapport aux autres
implitations que nous avons he
rappelons-nous que nous sommes sur Paris
16 et à Montini ben vellisis c'est bien
au centre de tout ça il y a un grand
centre commercial il y a un gros une
grosse zone d'emploi c'est une zone très
dynamique ça convenait très bien à la
marque on va rester dans le domaine de
l'économie on va parler cette fois
d'immobilier il reste peu de réserves
foncières dans l'agglomération et à
guilloncour un programme de 32 logements
est en cours d'achèvement et les
logements ont tous trouvé
preneur Silence ça pousse les villas du
maille sortent de terre la première
pierre vient d'être posée ce mardi TR
ilos de 32 logement au sein de la zag
Villarois le programme fait partie d'un
ensemble plus vaste comprenant 220
logements nous aurons aussi des
programmes en accession aidé y compris
d'ailleurs en location vente c'est des
locataires qui pourront propriétaire et
là ce sont évidemment avec des critères
et pour l'aiguille en courtois
l'opération est labellisé Bâtiment Basse
Consommation et Habitat et Environnement
devant ainsi la réglementation à venir
sur les matériaux en fait les façades en
fait on a une partie qui est habillée en
pierre l'autre partie en fait du
bâtiment en fait c'est une isolation par
l'extérieur avec un endui et donc l'idée
en fait c'est d'avoir un bâtiment très
bien isolé la livraison est pré pour le
dernier trimestre 2013 les 32 logements
ont déjà tous trouvé acquéreur au prix
de 3600 € le mètre carré un peu moins
que le prix moyen pratiqué dans le
département qui avoisine les 3900 €